The kids took off.
That's sad.
network you watch is sort of
what story you're going to get.
the Rio Grande? I can show
you what's going on currently",
here, risking their lives and
at the end of the day for what?
the US/Mexican border on the
Rio Grande River. As many of
that. So... Let's dive in, push
the boundaries as much as we
you know, there's been an influx
of migrants coming over the
So we're going to do this a bit
differently and this is about
and I said: "Definitely! Let's do
this". So I'm going to give it
seeing the situation through
the eyes of the locals.
views of looking at the world.
My goal in this series (there's
sounds like cartel. There's a raft crossing?
Look at that way. We don't know
the law like yesterday haha.
That's a bus full of illegal
every view of the situation.
But from what I've seen so far,
know they have a free pass.
What do you guys think is the
It's either they do or they're
going to kill 'em. That's
down there. So there's just a
lot of money being made here?
They're the ones that get
I'm no expert on the border
situation, I'm fully aware of
So what's the story here Raul?
How do we get through this?
So I had a local reach out to me,
he said: "Do you want to get on
a stash house? Just across from
that side of the river to this
side, they're paying... These
guys, like I said, they're out
Once they get into the
United States, they basically
is actually a private property,
so even though border
situation on the ground level.
More listening, less talking.
immigrants coming this way.
Oh you can record. I can record?
Yeah. Usually for government stuff
last few months. And as many of
you also know it's sort of hard
private entity, so that's all
private property. Camera down.
Raul navigating this
mission. Somewhat :)
where the hell they're at, but
they know exactly where we're.
solution to this thing? See, I wave to them,
they all wave back.
Good afternoon guys here in
McAllen, Texas, a few miles from
to get a story that's not
biased, depending on what
So what's the business model of
this? This guy here definitely
my best guys. Everyone has an
opinion. Everyone has different
going to head that way. We're
going to head that way? We got
Here we are, I guess the river's
on the other side there. We're
scr*wed in all this.
to irrigation district, so they're
going to come and open the gate
Well, they got a $10000 reward
for her return. Okay. There's a
it sounds like it's a county or
state entity, it's not. It's a
there's nothing they can do about
it. I always push everything to the
going to be a few videos here)
is to really capture the
important. So today on the Rio
Grande with the local, let's see what
know someone who knows someone?
On the other side of the gate
it's not okay. As long as it's
in the view of the camera,
for us. Okay. That
irrigation district even though
we can get into.
can, but obviously, I won't be
able to get in everything or
going to have to do this again
tomorrow.
it's quite... it's saddening.
It's interesting. It's
We're going to have somebody
open the gate for us. So you
limit. That's why I know how
far I can go without breaking
with the boat, who has the
access now we're getting on the
Alright guys. So that's how
these things go sometimes when
patrol doesn't like it or
anything, the property belongs
and guys I want
to let you know that without
Day two on this mission, we're
on, we got our guy, our contact
Rio Grande.
haven't confirmed that it's
her yet or not. I guess it's a
A lot going on as you can tell:
here's the border, the border
reason they're fleeing their
country. Every morning, around
body that they found about
fifty miles south of us. They
patrol on the river, obviously.
I don't know what that is.
United States. As a matter of
fact, I was looking at Facebook
That's Mexico! That close!
You see how you
have you seen a big like,
there's a big increase or tough
Well? I can't tell you number
wise, the only way to look at
the stats, see what the
stats and everything else show,
you're getting into the harder
shoots, which this is. We're
it when the calls come in and
stuff so they just gotta get a
there that way, if the electricity
shuts off - they're still able
he's part of the United Cajun
Navy, which in short what are
to supply water to the city of
Mcallen and whoever else.
So I want to be clear: this is
still the US side. It's just
the fences back from the river,
so we didn't cross into Mexico.
bunch of illegal aliens hidden
there. So there's no
boat coming down, this is Raul's
friend. Raul (little background),
warrant for it. That's it.
yeah? Yeah, exactly now there's
certain times that are busier
That's a pump house. That's a pump
house? Okay. They got generators
just trying to show the people
in the world that you know what
missing person case he's dealing with.
The border wall... They can also trace
and take it from there. But
like I said, physically,
guarantees, sometimes they're
busier than others, obviously,
nothing to do with immigration
or any of that stuff. We're
bulletproof vests on, but we're
out here without them. Is that
This is still US.
a little while ago in La Jolla.
They got about 600 people
day, the time, a whole bunch of
factors, but one thing we're
detained within 2 hours.
But United Cajun Navy,
Alright, and here's our boat
ramp, huh? Yeah. We got the
I'm going to start
with some basic questions, but
there is a problem of people
coming this way for whatever
like the dad with the helmet
and the kid doesn't have one?
have the the dirt that comes
down the cleaned areas? Yes.
you guys doing out here?
Basically we got a crisis going
these guys I wouldn't be getting
here, that's for sure. We got
there's a doughnut up here.
We'll get out of the area if
where they put that gate down
there), you'll find a
than others because they know
the change of shifts for law
enforcement. So are we hitting
a busy time? We should be hitting one.
you'll see people in the line
waiting to get on the raft
on people, fleeing from their
home countries, headed to the
five in the morning down there
in that fencing area (that's
You'll see places that have
houses or ranches or whatever
That's where people come down
to those areas right there.
nothing. But you know
what, they want the story to be
that? Border Patrol
supervisor. Alright.
to say or nobody's really
counting or how does that work?
forth two or three rafts at a
time. And as he said,
inside information and stuff.
It's your buddy John with the
to come across,
and they'll go back and
out there, so they'll
give us
because if we do, that means we have
to come to a port of entry to
We don't need it. I mean unless
it's an emergency, but yeah,
Now they have a gag orders
on them where they can say
everything's going to be over
here. That cooperation. Who told him
Slowly! No guarantees on what
we're going to see. Depends on the
not here. You want to
put one on you put one on.
going to learn is exactly about
what's going on in here
Yeah, that truck's pretty dope.
So let me ask you this Raul. Yes.
You and John have the
there's a life jackets over
there, just so you all know,
sweet boat. The hell with the
boat, look at the truck!
You're safe, don't worry my son.
You are safe. You'll see
I can swim pretty well, but if I get
shot, then I don't swim well.
I'm the one getting wet.
And this is Maya. Maya is also in
currently from these guys,
who are out here all the time.
the United Cajun Navy. Should
we wear these or no? No that's
around the river. Wow. So the
homes are right here and then
the pathways where people come
down. Okay. You'll see areas
today, remember that.
Going in!
Alright. No bullets but occasional
rocks? We're all going home
Come on, people live right here?!
They live right here, yeah?
The majority of these where you see
the cleared out area, they're
come back to the United States
even though we are on the water.
something's wrong, we'll get
out of there, don't worry.
that. So what's the law
here? We can be on on this side
these are the pathways?
Or what's going on exactly?
like they got debris there or
whatever debris that they might
left is the United States, from the
middle of the river to
have thrown water bottles, cans,
their clothes and stuff like
of the river? From the middle of
the river to my
middle of the river to the left
only, we can't cross into Mexico,
the right is going to be
Mexico. So we can be in the
last few months. What's really
going on, what happens when
across. But okay, if
our border patrol is
States, they basically know
they have a free pass, because
Well walk us through exactly
what's going on currently at
bring the mask down?
OTM stands for "other
basically they've made an open
door for people to come into
US guys. What's their story
right now? Basically they're
the United States. Once they
get to Mexico over here,
how they're going to cross.
Once they get into the United
the border, like what do you see?
You guys live down here.
they're the ones who
are going to get caught and get
There's been an influx
obviously of migrants over the
else, they'll allow you
into this country. What about
they'll say: "You know what,
we're monitoring the Border Patrol".
seen so far it's mostly women and
children. The majority is women
released. Okay. But what they
do is they'll send the families
Middle East, Africa, those
countries? As far as I know
So other than Mexicans, the
migrants come over, what I've
they'll cross
the river in rafts or
than Mexicans". Basically if you're
from Mexico, they'll
and children. So what's the
business model of this? They
and stuff one direction and
then the other directions where
they'll stage them in a
stash house. From there
they cross? Literally, since new
Administration took office
since the new administration
took office, they have 100 day
100 days of no deportation.
So what that means is, if you're
taking them in no matter,
then why do they need the coast to be
clear? Because not everybody
wants to be cought, like I said. If
While they're monitoring,
they're moving and
through here, correct? Basically
what they're doing, they're
that the coast is clear.
Then they'll go ahead and bring them
They're out chasing people
through a rugged kind of
putting their lives on danger
trying to do their job.
So there's just a big game right
now? Cat and mouse, cat and
deport you back to Mexico.
If you're from anywhere
smuggler, they're bringing them
across, put them to the United
more of these guys? Yes, what
happens right now since they
people so they can get into the
country. Since Border Patrol is
paying somebody on that side,
which what they'll do is
stuff. Then they'll bring
people down to the river, say
then they're able to try to
get into the country.
right back and load up another
one and just... But
100 day no deportation. These
guys are risking their lives,
the day for what?
They need the nation to know
terrain, some get hurt. Some
are not protected by the
they'll send your Africans, your
Chinese and all those other
OTM ("other than Mexican"), you
will cross it to. OTM? Can you
those countries will
be deported back. Okay.
have a coyote on this side that
they're paying to navigate them
they're from South America,
border patrols from all around
the country this way. They're
vaccine and stuff due to COVID,
but they're out here doing
tied up on one side, they send
them to the other side and
mouse. Yes. What about
the border guys over here the
States side and "hey, get out, get
out, get out and then he'll go
that side of the river to this
side, they're paying $3,500,
trying to do their job, but
they can't due to the to the
Just imagine what they're
charging and this is coming
able to be in this area for
whatever time period is needed.
their job because that's that's
what they get paid to do.
setting them up at hotels and
stuff, and that way they're
have so many people crossing,
they're bringing out
said, they're out here, risking
their lives and at the end of
correctly. The illegal aliens
are saying: "Hey, here I am, you're
my taxi ride" and stuff and it's
like, come on, these guys, like I
that there is a
problem, an immigration
So there's just a lot of money
being made here? There's a lot.
because they're
not able to do their job
increase of guys here, because I
noticed in my hotel there are
kill them. Well, they might be
getting paid because you know
from some of the people we've
talked to: just across from
for us to leave. So what do we
do? Hide and then hit full
cartel? They would have to pay
the cartel. So the people that
what I was saying was: if you
are a solo person, Honduran,
And like I said, at the end of the
day they get demoralized,
something to give, and give
quickly, so that these guys can do
problem, and our
administration needs to give
own the ranches here they have
to let the coyotes and the
their job efficiently and get
things done right. Is there an
the cartels. There's no way to get to
this line without running into the
Option one or option two, it's
like I said, or they'll kill
just the river iself.
They have their
got scouts over there, you got
scouts over here. You don't see
actually talk to the cops and
go through a process here.
what, you know what: "Here, shut
up. Stay out of my way".
it happens in Mexico, either
they do or they're going to
fear, because if
deeper into Mexico, you'll have
you and says "I'm going to take
away your land, I'm going to
If they're the landowners, I
think they just do it out of
world and realize, that's how
the systems work in different
Guatemalan, whomever and you
wanted to do it yourself? You gotta pay
hell they're at, but they know
exactly where we're at.
about it: oh, we're letting
them to a better life type
there's no way in hell they
can do it on the US side.
your land and that's it", and
what do you do? Yeah, you don't
If some mafia dude says they
want to use my land, I can
Something you don't realize
until you go to a lot of the
him. Yeah. And it can also be
looked at is a lot of people
because we don't see that in one part
doesn't mean it's not happening
all depends where you're
standing. Okay because you
cartels just control their land
or what? Basically - yes, the way
Yeah. But usually you don't
have someone that goes up to
caught, whether they're from
Africa, China, Russia.
are fleeing bad situations and
I bet they (ranchers) can feel good
As soon as we're out of
a sight, they'll cross? They're waiting
somewhere else. As soon as we're out of a
a sight, they'll start crossing again.
go to the cops. Most of the
cops are paid off, so yeah.
thing. Is that possible? I think
they just do it out of fear.
slowly come back so they don't
hear us, but you can hear
like a mic. Do you know they're
holding abandoned buildings and
GoPro? Haha, they don't know what the
hell you're holding, it looks
they've been there for a long
time. So why would they dump
places. And you come back to the
States and you're like: oh wow!
different cartels going on and saying:
"You know what, I'm taking over
houses. It's all the debris
that's left over when they
this engine from way down the
river. Even though it's like
crisis here? There's...
you don't see much? I mean it
use your land". It doesn't even
happen here. At the end of the day
They know exactly where the
hell we're at, because I said I
And that raft just went
back I think. Yeah, let's hold
somebody that's somewhere in
that brush. They're yelling at
Exactly. So guys, it can be
fair to say that there's no
to come from Guatemala this way.
$15,000 from Guatemala?
that, you can hear it. Trust me.
They're monitoring everything.
gotta remember this is a long
river, a long border. So just
day I was having a
conversation yelling at
than Mexican), then why have
lookouts? Because we don't know
me. I'm yelling. Then we're
communicating back and forth,
throttle back? No. I'm going to
try to go that way and then
what exactly is crossed, you might
have had a few people carrying
border patrol will take them in
no matter what is it (other
Yes. How's that possible?
How they come up with the money
stuff? I'm going to assume
they're stash houses and
You can't see them but they can see us.
So they see Gringo with the
so that's what I'm telling you,
that we don't know where the
change it. What do you do with
all the stuff? There's a
Other people that pay high
dollar to come into this
all their clothes before
getting over the border? No,
packs of drugs or something
or, like I said, that's the
him, and the reason why, I tell,
you don't see him, the other
on, let it come this way.
But okay the part
country. Well, I said, maybe the
normal people pay $15,000
what happened, I said there's
stash houses, so there's stash
I'm not understanding is, if
they can get over and
They took it up. Alright guys.
There's a raft that I don't
there's a raft crossing the river.
Let's go that way. We got action.
people that they
don't want to get
I have no idea.
think the GoPro captured, but
it went right up. So right here
in this area. Yeah don't be
fooled, it's not a family just
over, right? Because once they're
there, they're
seekers, they wouldn't care
that we're here? They just go
let in right? Well, like I
said, even though they know
border patrol, now people
that are maneuvering the boats
other countries. They're trying
to sink their way into this
they're going to be caught, but
whoever the ones that are
caught or people that are
wanted from, you know, sexual
boats and stuff like that,
if all of a
having leisure time, that
family's out there or whoever
but yeah, they pay them.
They're like
So the cartels will pay the kids.
They'll pay them whatever
to be caught, they don't want
those rafts to be caught too.
country. Ok, so it's a bit of
everything.
So the guy paddling the boat,
he could get caught by US
people don't get caught.
Imagine every time they
caught. They get caught?
Yes, they don't want their people
...that it's not just people that
are wanting to get caught.
on this side, they
don't want their own people (scouts)
That's really why they have to
watch what's going on, so their
watch out.
So guys, just to make it clear,
if these were normal asylum
border. Yeah, that's what
they want. Gotcha gotcha.
You need to understand...
They're smuggling.
but people down the river,
so they'll all
are caught. Those boats to the
United States are going to get
these days is about profit and
money. That's why they charge
it is, they're all going to
be reporting down the river,
There's people that are wanting
to come across and not get
sudden they come in the raft,
and a boat is there, and it's
That other one is
loaded ther. They're
You'll be surprised how trained
these kids are. Yeah. How
they pay them.
I'm just giving you an amount,
people or their own operation
at risk. And it's the kids
Happy? Sad? It's sad
what they're doing because you
there and playing, letting
know if anybody shows up.
caught either. The scouts are
watching out for border patrol
what they charge, and they
don't want to put their own
trained they are? Trust me that
little kid's making $20 sitting
they're expensive. So imagine
they lose a raft every time
did something and they have
2 or 3 rafts.
Like I said that's $20 in Mexico,
it's a lot of d*mn money.
that get roped into this cr*p?
The majority of the time - yes.
They all wave back.
they come out. It cuts into
their profit, and everything
there and see it? They're
there, they're running down.
Those rafts
are not cheap,
crimes, people wanted for
other crimes and sh*t from
scouts believe it or not.
Wave to them.
going to alert someone else.
Yeah, he's moving. It's just a
They're down in the
grass or what?
now, but we just...
Can we go quick? Can we get up
It's like Border Patrol yeah,
border patrol is sitting here.
little change like he might
have been ready to cross right
How's this make you guys feel
living on the border?
it up.
Oh, he's got a goat.
The minute they (patrol) go that
way, they (smugglers) come this way.
it. Yeah. We actually found a
dead body farther down on the
Go quick
because they're going to pull
know what they take the risk
and they might not even make
drones, if they fly - helicopters.
How is it a tool,
might get raped and whatever
else might happen along the
they sliced it in half. So like
I said they they do take the
way. So it's saddening
because you know what,
out here and let people
know around the world, what's
going on you don't
know what's going on, you don't
Yeah. That's true, good point.
So in McAllen, the big city
they put their lives at
risk for what they're doing.
Mexico side, so we couldn't
approach it, but it looked like
They actually throw a
ladder up on that fence and
sending people away in the
airport and bus stations. You would
cleared, there will be people coming
down the hill or wherever.
How do you feel about on the US
side? Living on this side and
risk and there's other people
that might get the females that
see it. It's like a normal life
here in the Valley.
day, like I said, if you don't
have people like you to come
They're heading back, they're coming
out from behind.
vehicles. Your Atvs, your
motorcycles, your horses,
Arizona, they literally built a
ramp to drive over the wall!
They literally did that!
That wall is just another tool.
So do you know
any of these guys? Nope, you
what's going on from your
perspective? At the end of the
over the border here,
until Raul showed me (and
your aero stat balloons that
are up there,
cross right there, you got an
empty parking lot, you got a
never really know anything's
happening. I wouldn't, unless I
but it's basically the
old drainage system into the
saying? Yes, you can
actually go around the fence.
where the Catholic
organization is, that's
working, what's
the point? The wall is
Oh, yeah there's a tunnel over
there that is sealed off,
plaza, and you got
hundreds of people already
would need to have in that area
to monitor it. Okay. But
just wave at them and let them
know we are no threats to them.
they'll hop that fence right
there in front, because once you
these are the other videos)
where the COVID testing is,
don't understand.
That wall, like I said,
not there to actually stop
anybody. The wall is just
went in with you.
they cross, they get lost into
those people. If the wall is not
So this is the crossing, the US
Mexico border. Once you get it
everyone comes with their own
ladder, that's what you're
There's a raft right there.
That's where they're coming up there
You got agents that are your
tool. You got your
here one, over here and maybe one
in the middle. So not
to the those huge tunnels, take
up their drugs and do whatever
another tool to help out border
patrol. That's what people
I know in other states that have
done tunnels. Yeah, but as far
if it's not working so well?
It does because what happens..
if there's a fence, ang you got a
gap over here, and a gap over
you put a ladder against it. In
New Mexico I believe or in
This is your fence
right here. Okay.
as going under it, I have no
idea, it has not been done here
here, that means you just
really gotta put one agent over
walking there doing shopping in
those in those plaza. So once
yet. On the way back, there's a
tunnel.
and the wrong way. The right way
is to come on this - this is your
What about going under it? Going
under? That.. I have no idea.
Pretend there's no fence,
imagine how many agents you
city, and back in the day
the cartel did use that to
the area. These guys are
getting ready to cross.
That's why there's
a right way to do this
that's the proper way to do it,
not crossing the river and
who exactly is coming over, but
it's a collection of everyone,
right? It's an innocent mom,
it's a hardworking guy from
bad situation, it's a drug guy,
it's a human trafficker guy.
they're going. So right
now it's really hard to know
smuggle drugs into the United
States, because they were going
Camera's on on the US side
here. Okay, you're going to see
for them because border patrol
spots them and they want to get
away, all they gotta do is
raise back home, get on the
They're looking out and
they're making sure the air is
saying: "Hey, I'm
seeking asylum".
clear. And you and guys wave
to each other why?
house. They have their own
private ramps. They can launch a
"You know what, I'm here to claim
asylum. I got a problem in my
footbridge - come,
you're going to walk in and say:
their thing is their thing.
We don't care. We ain't getting
are no threats to them.
To let them know that
a cartel stash house, you're
going to see possibly a drug
ramp and they're done. Yeah. So
I said, I'm just watching out
We gotta be friendly.
Let them know that we
just here to video and take
footage and that's it. And I
boat off at any time. The drug
house? Yeah. And it's easy
we're not here to
interrupt their
conversations with them where
they'll say, hey, let us do our
operation. We're not here to do
anything against them. We're
want to let them know if there's
time where we'll get into
job. We say hey, we are no threat to you.
Do whatever you're
going to do. We're not cops.
We'll let them know that
this? Well, there's the family
right there.
not border patrol. Here's some
more guys behind you. What's
practically have the
same border, but I can't answer
part? Of course they have to
bring their family out here.
might have dug a certain
section where they haven't hit
He's got a work badge, there's
some waving going on.
be sent back other than
Mexican. From what Raul said,
They all are going to
play the part. They play the
the other side of the hill
where we don't see it or they
involved. We're here for a
whole different purpose. We're
no raft down there. Oh they
might have it right there on
come all the way from deep in
the Central America, this is
He's explaining to the woman whatever
he's explaining to her. Giving her a
They're going to play the part
that they're here as a family,
infringe too much on you.
And there's that, you know, game
weeks to get here, but I didn't
ask where they were from.
but they're actually looking
out. You know somebody gotta be
been using. It's fresh* -
so they know they spent
what you see that tower right
over there. Once you get to
to get here. This is the last
stop and once I get to the US
that tower take a ride or
whatever, because he is pointing
getting paid. So how's that mom
and kid getting across? There's
there ain't nothing to point at?
What is this?
the people from Central America
most of them, they're selling
nervous as hell and super
euphoric at the same time -
other video on the process
of what happens after they
the end of their journey. Yes.
It's the last stand for them
child, I'm sure they're going,
and they just need to get over
and they know, if they get there -
*that's the path they've
thousands and thousands of
dollars, how many months do you
and that's... I'm trying to get
into the mother and the child's
know? We're starting
to think that maybe
back and forth. Quite surreal
out here guys. You were saying
who knows? right. Why would you
point at the United States side and
this is the last stop,
they probably went through hell
and maybe some Middle Eastern
or Asian countries, but Central,
strategy of how to get across?
Well, they can say you know,
or something. Oh my God so that
mother and child might have
because it hurts that country,
the country of Mexico. Why
The Mexico president is also mad
with all this open door policy,
military right now, hovering
above us or whatever. I said,
I can't tell you what they do or
how they do it. I can lie to you
to this side and talking to her
So what he's telling her
head. It's probably like
they're probably feeling
the cartels took over this
place and this is what they
think to get here from Central America?
I've talked to some people on the
Interesting how they all wave
to each other, like they all
everything they have: their home?
Anything just to get over here,
South America, they get there -
they're in. I did the whole
months to get here. There's
some people said it took 2
understand: don't infringe
too much on me - I won't
launched out of. You saw those
guys up there. Mother and
they had an agreement with
Mexico, that way they would keep
river, they've taken 2 months.
The longest I've heard - up to 4
and tell you something, make up
something, but that's not
side, they're in, they know they're
in, because that's the way
things are right now. Mother
and children are not going to
get to the US side.
anything. So what do you
guys think is the
administration's policies,
Because what happened
know what we're going to
forgive everybody from this day
McAllen or whatever which
probably won't happen. But even
but I've seen a man been arrested before
for doing something. There's no universal recipe,
Why is legal process so shady?
I've seen mostly women and children,
you do have their stuff now, how
they operate - I have no idea.
not only Hispanics. We're Hispanics.
So we're from Texas, and then
Trump eventually made that
that agreement with Mexico.
in? The Democrats", so they're
going to stick with that.
topics we have these days.
They're going to re-implement the prior
but I don't want to float into..
Okay, yeah, don't worry.
Okay, but it's fair
to say last election more
have a shorter Border.
Well, they
them on that side and they
wouldn't come to this side.
solution to this thing? t's
like one of the most complex
days. You don't find it
confusing at all or
I understand the whole point why people
go for a better life, I would do the same thing
American citizen. Here's your
papers. Here's your social
Yeah, clear up my confusion please.
you could say they have their..
we might run into the
going to happen. Yeah, don't do it.
I can clear up your confusion.
citizens and those are
going to be votes for him.
security". Aren't you going
to be grateful to whomever did it,
don't they protect their border
better? They even
that, I have no idea. If people
are getting paid off? Well you
are that.. can you cut the
engine? Do you mind? I could,
manner, but he got 100 days,
let's go. But okay,
on the other side, they
come over, they have to get
why I'm confused.
It stops after the 100
what's your take John?
Living here? My thoughts
eventually all these people are
going to become
My thoughts are that..
stupid thoughts, I guess.
people are fleeing their
country because this person
Democratic Party,
they're going to say: "Who let me
which is your president or
the Democrat?
But in this
case these
hired a guy a long time ago, he
came to the States, when he was
chance without no problems to
say: "You know what, you're an
I mean you can dig so far too,
you can go back and Republicans
You're right, Hispanics and we
do have a lot of even Mexicans,
that's why. But I don't see anything.
I don't see how this is
But like I said at the end of
the day, they say, hey, you
Exactly. He'll be dead
by then. Well, votes for the
you have Mexicans from Mexico,
that do support Trump also.
sustainable, like how it can
keep going indefinitely. That's
used to bring illegals for
cheap labor in the Central
asylum papers, they have to
come back to a court date in
situation when someone is
detained and they're thinking
everything the right way. She's
an American citizen now. So why
Hispanics voted for Republicans.
pretend you were from Honduras,
and they gave you a
I'm thinking that Biden's getting all
these people over here,
It's not just us but what
happened in this case:
give amnesty to
everybody", just like they
Valley, California.
I understand all that.
it's a delicate situation,
because what happens there? He
days". That's basically what he
did, and he didn't do it in that
that stuff, and I know that's a
very touchy situation.
gave him an opportunity and said:
"Come, come, let's go. You got 100
tried to do back a few years ago
with the doctor and all
if they don't, you still go back
to you "We're going to
got her process done.
Okay. What about this? So I
I'll just give you an
example. My wife did
I've have been here since I was 3
years old", and prove that in
resident card. She got a
resident card and from there
their own that they are over here,
and now they want to deport
on or whatever, now what?
And then that will piss people off.
3 months old, he doesn't even
speak Spanish. That's why
can't everybody? How'd she come
over? She came over with a
into consideration, because that is a
delicate situation:
are going to let you stay in
this country, unless he
doesn't even know Mexico. You
would have to go a case by case
they were born in Mexico,
and no fault of
don't even want American
citizens have done that to kids
them. So that has
to be worked out and I guess
she went ahead and started
working and stuff, and then she
argument that the current
policy is because it's
you would have you would have
to actually prove that: " You know,
committed a felony and then
there'll be something different
about deporting them back,
and the judge would take this
means let's get him the heck out of
this country. Yeah, because I
and stuff to be in this
country. What about the
some way, whether it's with
school records or whatever,
something to a minor or
somebody, you know, by all
That way they
can go and say you know what, we
like they got him a
traffic ticket or something,
that's totally wrong. But if
he did a felony or he did
humanitarian? It's helping
people out, they're coming from
a sh*tty situation? But how do we know it's
the actual true story on each
and every single person? Maybe
some yes, but... Maybe some
looking for the opportunity,
like I would be, I would be
the valley that are illegal.
They're all good people. I got
there's also a right way to
come into this country and a
running around. I know a
lot of people that live here in
every 3 months for border
security. How did I get those
nothing against anybody.
You know you have the right to do
case. The state of Texas should
be spending about 25 million
them on the water was parked
right there and this ramp right
whatever to make your life,
and live your life, and get
here. So that boat is the
one that showed up with them
wrong way to do it. Yeah.
That boat that came upon
ahead in life, never hold
anybody down. But like I said,
everything, that's what it came
out to, they gotta pay housing,
numbers? The last time we did
this thing, when they brought
which are hotels for the
national guard. They gotta pay
in a thousand national
guardsmen and DPS and
paying for besides the payroll
and everything else. So they'll
throw money to DPS's fund
so they can support all this.
you put one on one together,
it's going to equal two in this
actually safe to live with your
family. And I understand,
hotels for DPS.
They gotta pay for
people up there in the top
floor to watch. You got
He worked for the
sheriff's department. He lost
the food (for all three meals)
and whatever else they're
understand it's needed.
I understand. What I'm
used too. I mean it ain't there
just to be. You put
side over here. Do you see the
type of glass that's up there?
over there with seven armed
people with machine guns, so if
that's just an abandoned
building, but there's an AC
going to do if got that flux? But
there is no need to say you
pit in there. The governor
of Texas claims that this is a
spend about 25 million every
3 months for border security.
the state of Texas.
So they're going to take
away money from education and
whatever else to be able to
Twenty-five millions, okay.
And then the FEDs, who knows, huh?
extra manpower dedicated for
border security through
the bird's eye view of
whatever's going on this
What were they paying before?
Well, nothing, but
what happened? I said this is
before the surge. Oh! This is
Yes. And then you can sort of
dissolve into the population,
That's reflected. it's
reflecting, yeah, and a barbecue
no AC on it. What do you mean?
No AC means stash house? No, no,
government: "These are our
numbers. This is what we're
county at that time maybe for
about 17 years.
might be doing it, but they're
getting government funding.
is: we need more
money for this, we need more
getting hotels, they're getting
their meals paid for, they're
wearing a Kevlar vest, so the
Valley is not a war zone. It is
situation with a kid?
Let me give you a story here. My
want to try to get reimbursed.
For every person that comes in and
You weren't dodging
bullets anywhere, you weren't
says a $1,200. They have a
picture of them, they have their
operations, like I said, are
costing millions to do, so they
is get to from this side, this
is the last step. Once you get
He was living off credit card
by credit card. This credit
unit right there by the second
window. Yeah, it's gotta be
the value is a war zone,
because you went out to
everything's about government
funding and that's what it
money for that, so the
governor tells the federal
Once you get those walking
papers that allow you to go
war zone, they're paying
DPS hazard pay and right now I
paperwork. They have all that
stuff. Some are
The Border Patrol might be doing
it, but they're getting
government funding, and where
did the government funding come?
From the normal taxpayers.
Yeah, and all they have to do
because you can go anywhere, right,
once you get to the USA?
eat the other day alone. You
didn't get shot at. Yeah.
there, you get all of those
things you're talking about.
doing. This is the operations
we're running". Well, those
they're getting that packet.
That packet is like the rumor
You don't have to come back for
your court date. Okay, but
card pays this bill, and this
one pays that bill and so on.
Nothing's for free in this
world, so the Catholic charity
anywhere in the United States,
you can disappear anywhere.
they denied him. Why?
They said he had two
but he lost his job. He was
almost 2 years without a job.
his job for whatever reason, I
won't go into detail on that,
dad is Vietnam War
veteran, my dad worked for the
getting clothes to put on and
stuff all paid for by somebody.
coming in for almost 2 years.
I'm a Vietnam veteran, and I've
guys, don't you feel empathy for
the mom, that's fleeing some sh*tty
vehicles. He went: "Yes. I have
two vehicles. I'm paying on
He went to go ask for government
assistance, food stamps, whatever,
one time I do come for help,
y'all to deny me?" My dad, he
said: "Look at those - and I'm
going to excuse my word I use -
That's sad.
They're
They're getting ready to cross here.
look at those sob's in the
lobby.
passed. So now if they only got
fifteen people here, they're
So that was the end of that.
My dad was pissed. So this is one
for coverage, look over here!
They're all scared... They're not
fisherman, they're scouts.
issue, but all of a sudden
everything went silent. Why?
maybe even more. And the US side
guys, different reality, even
going on. Yeah.
They're scouts.
That's sad guys.
plus food stamps, and why? I'm an
American citizen. They're not".
never asked this country for
sh*t, and for you to deny me the
you're going to give them
everything they want: money
Different flow? Oh, no? No.
We've got the same flow coming in and
right on top of each other, and
I don't want to say Mexico is a
issue now, maybe about 2 weeks
ago, 3 weeks ago, it was a heavy
of the most politicized issues
would you say yes, right now?
Well it was, but then all of a
sudden they put a pause on it.
just seeing nature. I mean no
trash. Two different worlds
on", - he went. "I got no money
coming in, haven't had money
There are very few
people that are pushing the
the ones that get scr*wed in all this.
And they're
They're full of gold watches,
cellphones, all this stuff and
That's for sure.
both of those vehicles. I'm
paying on the place that I live
We didn't see any
boats crossing, as you
very much mixed up country, so
this is not one of it's
cross to a certain area, so you
might get the sensor and say,
just sitting up in the tree, up
there, see that? Yeah. Ah man...
doing, huh? Aakes it even harder
with all these other BS that's
right? That's a massive a
expansion of what it was.
terrible country, because it's
not. I've had great times in
Get it! Oh, that looks like
it's an air mattress.
Mexico City and Oaxaca I went
to, that was cool. Okay. It's a
hanging out on a hot day.
I'm going to say yes for them. Yes.
Yeah, it's stuck.
Okay. What are those tires for?
They hide behind those tires
charming places. Not all Mexico
is like this border zone.
Well, that's a
glimpse of what it's like on
it, they help with all sorts of
disasters, and there's no way
the Rio Grande: cat and mouse game, right?
Basically yes.
There's sensors on the ground
that alert them and someone
yet? Not yet. Not yet. This is
the organization. And lastly I
Yeah, that's gotta to be a
tough job what these guys are
I'd be able to make these
videos without them. So if you
want to give to
hurricane or tornado relief or
and it's confusing. It's heavy.
It's a difficult situation.
twenty times. Sensors tell them
there's twenty bodies that just
you know, boom-boom-boom,
it just went off
I've never seen it, people there.
Before I've seen horses and
leave a link down below for the
United Cajun Navy. Raul is a part of
even here, I don't know if you
guys are doing anything here
So thanks for coming along
on that guys, I also want to
all looking for the
other five bodies that
they missed.
and from what I've seen with
the Donna processing facility
stuff, so that that's very well
just people on the Mexican side
could see, but it is a hot
place from what I've been told
gotta say this pretty
difficult content to get
We think that's a stash house.
I would say, yes, you see
border region in the playlist
below, thanks for coming along!
that. I'll have quite
a few other stories about the
But the stories need to be shown,
hope you got something out of
Until the next one.
So how's that mom and kid
getting across? There's no raft